Hello Freak bitches.
Satisfying.
I was in Vegas and I was sober and I ran into this chick that I know you used to
be a ring card girl and she was super,
super drunk.
Sloppy.
You're sober and so when else is not,
and you're like,
hey,
how are you doing?
How are you?
And they just like,
oh yeah.
By the way,
if you see people outside of a pink Floyd concert that you know,
please don't assume that they're just fine.
You know?
Don't just say,
hey man,
I haven't seen you in awhile.
Just fucking say hi and walk away.
Fuck Golan.
Yeah,
no,
please.
What happened?
Which was people saying hi,
but it's like,
I don't,
I can't talk to you right now.
Going to be cool.
I thought you ran into somebody they know.
Fucking hippie.
Yeah.
It's a very embarrassing thing when you're intoxicated and the other person
isn't.
Yeah.
You feel like it's a hassle.
It's such a loser.
Whether I'm drunk or whether I'm stoned,
I always feel like a real idiot if I'm drunk or coked up,
I feel like an idiot.
Yeah.
If I'm stolen,
I feel baffled.
You have the person.
If it's two in the afternoon and you ain't high,
go fuck yourself.
Go out on my face.
I want you around me like I want cancer,
my balls back and I'm saying you got to come around here looking at me with Yo.
Fuck a wide eyes.
Pick up that.
You know how whenever you I'm gonna Reform.
Go Fuck Yourself.
My morning starts at 5:30 AM either you're there or your square and I'm saying
it's true.
That's my new signature on the row.
Good Board.
If it's two in the afternoon,
UAA high go.
Fuck you.
Fuck is a shame on you,
bitch.
You're slipping,
you're slipping.
You're escaping.
If you have a fucking date,
unless no,
no,
no.
I want to give a shout out to the American people out there that work.
They have to get piss test you people got to fuck.
I'm writing about that.
I'm writing a bit about you guys.
I really do respect you guys.
I see people,
they come up to me,
it's so great to see you and they like talk to me about weeds.
I asked him if you want to smoke and they look at me with this pain of his soul.
Yeah,
but I understand your pain,
so you guys don't listen to the shit.
I love it all my,
you're the fucking Republicans and Democrats that walk around all day.
I don't get high for after work.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Lunchtime.
I don't mind.
You want to go in at nine I feel the fucking atmosphere and see what's going on.
You don't want to run it down high into a,
an emergency.
You know what I'm saying?
A 11 o'clock at 12 o'clock you slip off for lunch.
You've got to come with the kit.
Vaizey lifesavers
that
[inaudible]
okay.